you have to spend an hour arm wrestling
a client to sell a 1 000 package whereas
here people buy 40 000 packages over the
phone in less than 15 minutes
so when i was 28 years old i was five or
six years into business or my business
career
and i had just gone through a five-day
gauntlet so i had done a two-day client
event
which was we had six or seven hundred
clients uh that had come to our highest
level program in person and then the
next day i had my executive meeting then
two days after that i did a meeting uh
with all 135 of our employees who flew
out uh to austin to to to do a two-day
conference with us do some trainings all
that kind of stuff my dad calls me up
after this kind of five day marathon
and he says hey alexander because that's
what he calls me right
he says hey alexander but he sounded
really way more concerned and i was like
what's going on um and so i roll out of
bed put a hoodie on walking in the
hallway so i didn't want you know wake
layla
and he says
i thought you said this was just going
to be a meeting of your highest level
uh clients
and i was like it was he was like
didn't those people pay like 42 000 a
year the highest level people and i was
like yeah he's like but i thought but
you just said you had like 700 people
there and i was like yeah i know
and i was like what's the issue he was
like you had 700 people who paid that
much money
and i was like yeah what kind of came
next was
something that i think probably stung a
little bit at the time but i knew that
it wasn't coming from a place of
where i didn't think it was coming from
a place of of meanness
and he says
do they know that they're paying you
that much i was like
yeah they're aware it's not like i'm
magically siphoning money out of their
bank accounts
he's like
well i mean i hope i hope what you're
giving them is worth it that could have
really stung and it probably did um but
i think i was kind of in such an
emotionally exhausted state because if
you've done five days of just pure
events of it i was like i had no
adrenals to get angry with
and so i said well
let me walk you through it so i said if
i
made you 239 000
would you pay me forty two thousand
dollars
he's like well
how long would it take me and i was like
it would take
you know eleven months he was like okay
well do i know i'm gonna make that money
and i was like yeah you're pretty sure
you're gonna make the money it was like
okay
he's like what would i have to do
i was like you would you know wouldn't
have to do a ton you'd have to probably
do about 15 hours a week of work
he was like okay
um
and would i have to pay that all up
front or
like how would i have to pay you i was
like you would pay me as you made the
money
he was like huh
well then yeah i would do it
and i was like and that's why they do
too
and so when i walked my father through
that kind of mental explanation
partially part of it was to make sure
that my father you know felt like i was
legit but the other part of it his
questions actually uh denote
what the components of value are and so
the purpose of this video is to walk you
through the value equation which i think
you know might be one of the bigger
contributions that i'll have into the
the marketing world and there are four
components to value that's why i have my
little handy-dandy ipad here so we can
do this all visually alright so we'll
say value and we have the four
components of course of value to do when
i was creating this it was because i
wanted to figure out what this word
meant i think value is one of the
hardest things that we have as
entrepreneurs to understand we just say
it it's it's used loosely lifetime value
you know provide more value excessive
value blah blah blah right but we don't
know what it actually means and if you
ask someone what is value right how do
you just how do you describe value how
do you how do you measure or quantify
value i think this is my one of my
better things and so this is the value
equation as alex for mostly defines it
okay so there are four components to
this
the first component is what i consider
the dream outcome all right and when i
was thinking about this it all started
because i was really trying to figure
out why
some people would buy some things and
not other things
and at the at the very beginning of this
it was if i were selling to men in
general more men value making money then
losing weight right and so in general
the category of things that make people
money cost more for men
than the category of things of losing
weight and that's because the dream
outcome of making money at least for men
increases status more than losing weight
does and so as a result that is deemed
more valuable and so while i'll go
through each of these components i'm
going to give you two kind of examples
of one that exemplifies it and doesn't
exemplify it so that you can see it kind
of in the real world the first component
is is the thing that we are selling
valuable in terms of is the dream
outcome that we're going to deliver to
the prospect something that they would
like the reason this is probably the
first one is because it kind of defines
the category now within a category
the remaining three variables are the
things that will determine what is
expensive and what is not and to go back
to the the weight loss scenario if i
have uh a woman for example who wants to
lose weight and i sell there's probably
some things that help people lose weight
that are five dollars and some things
that help you lose weight that are fifty
thousand dollars so you've got a five
dollar ebook and you've got liposuction
all right so why is one five dollars and
150 000 when the dream outcome is the
same of losing weight that's where the
other three variables of value come into
play value number two and obviously the
goal here is to increase the dream
outcome the more the more appealing we
can make it seem the more viscerally we
can describe what the dream outcome is
going to be like when the when the
prospect experiences it then they're
going to deem it more valuable and then
by extension be willing to pay us more
for it the second component of value is
perceived likelihood of achievement and
believe it or not this was actually the
last of the four because i was still
trying to figure it out because i felt
like something was missing and so this
is the easiest example that i can give
you mentally for two things where one is
more valuable than the other based on
the perceived likelihood of achievement
and so for example if you were going to
get now we'll use liposuction as an
example if you're gonna get surgery
right from a from a from a doctor and
one doctor this is their first surgery
coming out of medical school and the
other doctor it's their 10 000th surgery
of this specific type of surgery which
guy would you be willing to pay more for
well obviously the 10 000 surgery guy
right i mean if anything you probably
have the the first time surgery guy
you'd want to do it for free or have him
pay you right and so
and what's funny about this just as an
added tangent is that the guy who it's
their first time would probably end up
taking longer so you're actually getting
less time with the guy who's done it 10
000 times than the guy who's done it
once or never right and so even though
you're actually getting less time you're
willing to pay more for it which is just
another interesting thing which is why
value is not uh time in terms of how
long it takes you to fulfill something
should never be
in the value equation for yourself all
right so first is dream outcome is the
thing that we're that we're going to
sell this the experience that they're
going to have would they imagine
themselves experiencing going to be
allowed to them second is how likely do
they perceive the achievement of that
dream outcome if i buy something right
like that ebook example if i'm buying an
e-book versus liposuction the likelihood
that i think that i'm actually going to
get the stomach that i want is probably
significantly lower with an e-book than
with liposuction right so the perceived
likelihood of achievement is lower and
by extension i will now get less value i
will perceive less value and be willing
to pay less for it and so for us as
business owners and promoters for our
businesses the goal is that in this
equation and the reasons a fraction is
that we want to increase both of these
things right we want to increase the
perceived likelihood of achievement and
when you increase the dream outcome this
is why a lot of marketers start
promising bigger and bigger things i
also believe that it's the most amateur
it's the most beginner but it's where
everyone starts alright this is where i
started my career where all i would do
is dream is is do bigger and bigger
dream outcomes i promise more and more
and the perceived likelihood of
achievement what i did is i put more and
more testimonials so the more
testimonials i had the higher the
certainty that the person or the
prospect would experience what i was
selling they believed me that if i had a
thousand testimonials versus one you
believe the person is better at the
thing right and if they're better at the
thing you're more certain which actually
decreases risk which becomes more
valuable third
so this is the bottom side of the
equation right so the top side of the
equation we're trying to increase the
bottom side of the equation we're trying
to decrease
all right so this is time delay
so the time delay is the time between
when i pay
and what i get what i want i have this
kind of in two separate pieces here well
i'll just i'll just talk about the main
one and then i'll talk about the about
the fourth one we'll hit it all right so
time delay and this is probably one of
if not the most powerful things like if
you want to enter into a marketplace you
can do whatever the best guy is doing
and do it in half the time and you will
become more valuable right people will
pay
for speed all right and if you ever
compete against somebody who's free or
giving away free stuff sometimes you
compete against government services i've
got a friend of mine who does dmv
expedited services in new mexico all
right and they have 14 locations of
basically
expedited dmv services so you can renew
your license and all that kind of stuff
and they cost 50 bucks instead of being
free from the government and they murder
it
murder it even though they're competing
at something that's free they beat them
on speed and so if you ever are
competing against uh free
compete with speed right fast speeds
free okay so time delay can i do the
thing faster can i get them there faster
now the longer it takes the less
valuable
my service or product is right the
shorter it takes the more valuable it is
so in theory if i were to click buy on a
digital product for a six pack and then
look at my abs and i have a six pack
that would be an infinitely valuable
product right and so if we can think
about our services as like how quickly
right can i make this happen in reality
a different example would be um if i
were selling marketing services right to
a physician and as soon as their card
ran their phone rang right on the front
desk with somebody saying hey i just
heard about your thing i'm qualified i'd
like to buy your services that would be
unbelievably valuable right immeasurably
valuable because of the speed right and
so you can in a very real way increase
the value of what you sell without
changing the thing but only delivering
the outcome faster that's the third
component of value so the idea here is
that we want to decrease the time delay
right we want to make it faster for the
prospect to experience the outcome that
we are promising
fourth component of value all right and
there's two components to this i'm going
to give you some nuances here it's
effort and sacrifice
so effort
is what someone must do
that they don't want to do in order to
achieve the outcome sacrifice
is what they have to give up or stop
doing that they do enjoy doing in order
to achieve the outcome so i'll give you
an example of both all right so it's
kind of like 4 4a and 4b right but i
think they're kind of i bulk them in the
same thing because i think they are
similar enough that they're worth uh
putting in the same bucket so effort for
example would be like if i wanted to
lose weight right
then uh if i'm you know cindy lou all of
a sudden i'm not doing certain things i
might not be weighing my food i might
not be counting my calories i might not
be eating you know shopping at the
healthy grocery store i might not be
working out in the morning i might not
be waking up right
early in order to get the gym i might
not have an extra hour or two
every day that i have to dedicate to
this i might not be sore right these are
all things that i now have to experience
that i don't want to experience that are
part of effort right these are things
that make this less valuable on the flip
side if i were to uh sacrifice i'm
sacrificing the foods i love i'm
sacrificing sleeping in i'm sacrificing
walking down the stairs without being in
pain and so i think effort and sacrifice
oftentimes are flip kind of
both sides of the coin right they're
either they're heads and tails of the
same concept which is why but i think if
you can think of that in terms of your
own services like what am i making
someone give up and what am i making
someone start doing that they weren't
doing before that they don't want to do
right and so again the goal here is how
can i decrease the effort and sacrifice
associated with achieving the outcome
when they buy from me the example would
be if i had the the abs thing right now
let's say it was instant but it was like
incredibly painful right well you
clicked the button then you get the abs
but it was just like it felt like fire
all over your body that would be a lot
of effort from sac i mean that's painful
right that's literally painful versus
nothing at all well in each of those
examples the one that isn't painful is
going to be more valuable right
and so as i think through product lines
service lines i always attack it from
this perspective all right is how can i
create more value by increasing the
dream outcome and my expression of it so
that they believe what i'm saying and
the way i have depicted what they want
to be actually what they want and you
would be surprised how many times people
get this wrong right i was talking to um
dr john berardi is the co-founder of
precision nutrition they sold for a a
nine figure plus exit he was talking
about one of the biggest breakthroughs
they had in their business when they
understood the job to be done all right
so they sold search certifications right
he said most people think that selling
certification is about selling continued
education he was like that's not the
dream outcome people are not actually
wanting to buy the certification the
dream outcome of the certification and
the experience around that is actually
being in a community and being meshed
with other people who are just like you
weird just like you and so as soon as
they realized that that was actually the
job to be done and people just wanted a
socially acceptable excuse to go do that
right certification is socially
acceptable excuse to do that then in
that instance now they had to find the
dream outcome properly as to what people
actually wanted right and so that was a
huge breakthrough in their business and
then business well up and all that kind
of stuff and so getting the dream
outcome right may seem simple but a lot
of times being able to depict it
accurately back to the prospect as they
desire it um is extremely valuable so
the goal is to increase the top side and
decrease the bottom side and one of the
things that and the reason this is a
fraction and not an addition and then
subtraction equation is that if you can
get these bottom things down to zero
right getting the bottom to zero you
have an infinitely valuable product so
no matter what your promise is on the
top even it's tiny a tiny inconvenience
you help people avoid if it's immediate
and it requires no effort on their part
you have an infinitely valuable product
and when i look at the biggest
businesses when i look at my own
businesses and how i've changed as an
entrepreneur over time i used to focus
only on the top side and now when i look
at the amazons i look at the netflix i
look at uber all of that stuff is stuff
that decreased the downside uber made it
immediate and you now you now if you've
seen on lyft you can be uh you can get
first in line right so it's like boom
you can hit it for an extra five dollars
you can get picked up an extra like in a
minute right it's crazy but they were
smart about it they realized they could
increase the value by decreasing the
time delay netflix made decreased all
the effort and sacrifice that went along
with watching television and seeing uh
and running movies and all that stuff it
was immediate for them right there's no
effort no sacrifice it's all right there
you don't have any picking it's just
boom they're like make suggestions etc
this theme amazon right you buy it and
then they've got drones delivering it to
you in two hours right they consistently
the biggest companies decrease the
downside of the equation which is where
more of the work happens but in my
opinion it's also where the biggest moat
lies from a competitive advantage
standpoint and so this as i look at my
companies this is what i'm focusing on
with our products and our services how
can we decrease the time delay how can
we how can we decrease the effort and
sacrifice that are associated with
achieving the outcome that we want and
then in so doing increase the perceived
likelihood of achievement of the pro of
the prospect so what i want to do is
give you one side-by-side example
of this concept so you've got personal
training and you've got uh lipo all
right so you've got both kind of
versions of the same dream outcome all
right so both stream outcomes are you're
gonna look good you're gonna feel good
all that kind of stuff right so i would
say this is a is a one out of one um if
we were to rate this on a binary scale
of does it achieve the dream outcome yes
personal training will help you look
good feel good etc liposuction help you
look good feel good etc all right now
look at let's look at the second second
thing here right perceive likelihood of
achievement if you're buying personal
training the perceived likelihood of
achievement probably kind of low right
because you're like am i really going to
do this am i really going to follow the
nutrition plan am i really going to wake
up you know am i going to do all this
stuff do i really think it's going to
happen for me probably put a zero most
people don't actually think they're
going to be successful when they buy the
thing now on the contrary liposuction do
you think that you're going to have less
fat on your stomach when you buy section
the answer is yes you do think that
you're going to have less so the
perceived likelihood that you're going
to do it very high which is a one let's
go to number three so time delay all
right so personal training am i going to
have it immediately no personal training
might take 12 months or 18 months or 24
months before i get to my ideal weight
and even then i still might not be my
body might not the way i want it to look
or my stomach might have extra skin all
that kind of stuff right so it's going
to take a long time for me to get to
where i want to get to right it's not
going to happen soon boom we've got
another another zero here now
liposuction if they just
suck all the stuff out of my stomach and
they cut the skin off right and it's
nice and tight right what's the like
what's the the time delay on that
i don't know maybe a month maybe two
months right before before it's it's all
ready and sucked in right so it's a
short and much shorter time time delay
for the dream outcome to occur and then
finally effort and sacrifice for
personal training all the things i gave
earlier right i gotta give i gotta i
gotta go i gotta change the way i shop i
gotta change the way i eat i gotta wake
up early i gotta be sore three days a
week right i might not be able to eat
with my kids like there's all these
other pains that go with i gotta learn
how to cook healthy all these things
right lipo i don't change anything
right the effort and sacrifices i i fall
asleep and instantly i'm woking back up
from my medical coma i am sore in my
stomach for sure you know for three or
four weeks but then after that it's done
right whereas here on this personal
training side right i'm going to be sort
of for
for years right now my goal here is not
to debate whether uh you know i think
people should do fitness or do
liposuction i'm obviously just do
whatever you want right but for the for
the for the context of us as business
owners to understand the difference in
value this is a one out of four and this
is a four out of four which is why you
have to spend an hour arm wrestling a
client to sell a 1 000 package whereas
here people buy 40 000 packages over the
phone in less than 15 minutes
and that is the difference of value and
that is why the value equation is how i
think that i this is how i see business
this has taken me a long time to figure
out and so i wanted to share it with you
guys so anyways lots of love keeping
amazing and if this was interesting for
you fyi my book just released um it's 99
cents you can get it i made it 99 cents
uh because as i said on this channel i
have nothing to sell you uh amazon takes
65 cents of that 99 cents um for you to
download so i want this to be affordable
for anyone and the goal of all the
things that i have here is um you know
we're trying to build a portfolio of
companies that does a billion dollars in
revenue we're currently at about 85
million um and that is why i have
nothing to sell you this is not how i
make my money um i know there are a lot
of broke people in the world and uh my
point here is to make sure that you are
not one of them and to equip
entrepreneurs with the stuff that they
need to succeed
without having to buy any courses on the
internet so uh keeping awesome lots of
love and see you in the next vid bye